he's come out of nowhere and we don't  know who he is what do we know about him  he's leading desperate people so this is  a cult we don't know who he's associated  with he could be creating an army or he  could be leading them to their death why  are you doing anything in this message  for my father your father who's lost  what do you mean he just disappears and  no one just disappears  we all witnessed a mirror  he's saved my daughter's life you need  to see this variant first long as you  can you didn't just click his heels in  and up here he merely had helped you get  around Syria Israel access soon hmm and  what is that work  consequently what do you think here you  didn't see what I saw and if I did would  I be calling in the second coming how  far will this new movement spread I'm  going to find out everything about you  this is bigger and what you can imagine  [Music]  you